hey everyone
i'm all share i'm the infra software
team lead at data jam
and i have experience with
over a decade of data engineering and
software engineering and today i'm going
to speak to you about
generating synthetic data at scale with
the help of modern execution
technologies
with some emphasis on the infrastructure
part
so
just before i will kind of uh go over
the agenda i would like to like get more
familiar with who am i talking to so
if you're a data data engineer software
engineer can you please raise your hand
okay i guess lots of nlp guys here right
computer vision
less okay so i guess
i can tell eyes and
that will go
uh so
we'll talk today about uh the first
thing we'll talk today what is synthetic
data uh in the scope of computer vision
um after that we'll
tell you a bit of the the journey of uh
of data gen
infrastructure
and then we'll kind of drill down into
the challenges we've faced during the
curation of um of our infrastructure
so um ai performance um as kind of said
uh before is uh kind of uh comprised of
two main factors
the first of them is the the model
and its quality and the other one is the
data and
the data that was kind of uh the model
was trained with
and there's a lot of uh ongoing efforts
regarding making the models
much better
and much faster much bigger and more
generalized
but
kind of the data part which have a lot
of potential is not kind it's not like
being used with uh to its fullest
[Music]
so
and and manual
also like said said before manual
annotation manual gathering of data is
kind of
um
kind of have a lot of challenges with it
um
and
and and
it needs a lot of human intervention
which means uh it will usually take a
lot of
time
and a lot of money
um and other than that is kind of prone
to a lot of
human and human errors
um
data privacy issues
and biases of course
[Music]
so
we at data gen our mission is kind of to
teach the ai to see
the world better with the use of
synthetic or simulated data
so
i guess there's there are not a lot of
computer vision guys here but
i i think uh that if they were they
probably think of synthetic data they'll
probably go for uh for guns generative
adversarial networks and we're not we're
not be talking about that today we're
talking about something a bit different
more
more controlled
so
in order to get um in order to get this
data this simulated data you first need
to kind of capture
real world 3d based content
by
by catching by by scans 3d scans or by
mockups or any any 3d content based on
the reality
and then you can create some
a variety of 3d environments
um
in a controllable way which is very
variant
and then you need to kind of extract the
data out of it with
some
annotations at a high
fidelity randy
so this in this example you can see one
3d environment
which
in every kind of object inside of it is
a is some other
separate 3d content the human being uh
the trash bin or the uh the saw the
the tables and even the the spoon if
there is one there uh the even the
tiniest piece here is
is kind of its own object and you can
see how we can take all of these um
kind of building blocks of 3d 3d
components and create a unique and
variety of different environments in a
programmatical and algorithmic way
so after we have
all of this variety of different
environments
we can then kind of extract the data out
of it think about putting some camera
inside of the 3d environment from one
point of view
and then
and then
render it it will usually
use lots of gpus just in order to do
that uh quickly
um and on the top left part you can see
some
image that is kind of the reality image
uh and this specific image is uh it's an
image that is
a nearly infrared in this specific in
this specific use case
and
all the rest are kind of the ground
truth and modalities of the same
image taken from the same point of time
from the same exact
moment and place
on the right bottom part you can see
the segmentation where each kind of
unique part of the the 3d scene is kind
of colored with a different
color and the other ones are talking
about
depth map and
normal map
so you can probably
guess how
how tds work it will be if you try to
manually annotate such such data and we
can get them in a in a pixel-perfect way
and other than that we can also generate
some textual data
textual
metadata about
the 3d environment
such as the the bounding cuboids of each
and every object inside of the scene
some key points like you see on the
famous face and on the driver's body
so
now that we've kind of understand better
what what it means
simulated or synthetic data in the field
of computer vision i'd like you to
briefly kind of take you into the
journey of data gen
specifically the infrastructure journey
so
kind of two years ago we were
getting uh
kind of adult projects from customers
specifying what kind of environments and
how what
how do they want their data to look like
and
we kind of created some scripts to
accommodate these variations of of
environments
and then we had like something like four
pc computers like you see here
uh which we called monsters because they
had lots of gpus uh cpu and them
and we kind of logged into each and
every one of them manually
ran the script and then probably a day
later or maybe even more it depends uh
came into the office kind of manually
collected the entire data set put it on
some hard drive send it away to the
customer
and of course this kind of was the naive
approach to two years ago
and of course it it's prone to a lot of
a lot of problems such as the cleaner
lady that comes and pulls out the blood
just because you want to clean beneath
and and she did it actually twice
yeah
and so
a few a few months later we kind of did
things
better uh at least
a bit better
and we've kind of put all of these
monsters into some somewhere
centralized some wreck
started to use
celery for the ones who
doesn't we're not familiar with celery
celery is some
some framework python framework for
distributed processing
so
now we were able to kind of
start kicking off the generation from
one central place making sure that the
entire computers
each of them will get their their own
part of the the generation
and but we're still wasn't it still
wasn't good enough of course because we
still wasted lots of resources and there
was no kind of a
central management of the entire
workflow
so
a few months later
we kind of started to create our own
workflow management system
we called it agne some kind of
some kind of an indian guard that was
responsible of passing messages between
the other guys or something like
something like that shy is the the
response the one that's responsible for
that name
um
and so
now we kind of did things better we
split the tasks uh into a more a
granular task which each of them had
different uh resource consumption
specifically the tasks that needed uh
the the the gpu rendering uh were kind
of uh by them on by themselves and we
have another central
entity that was kind of
orchestrating the entire world flow
um
but
of course it still wasn't good
because we
we still had those exact same 10 gpus we
had we had before
and
um customers requirements and and all
those
kept coming in and we
and we didn't uh we didn't made it on
time
uh so
we knew in we need to prepare to uh to
do to go into the cloud
where we'll probably have much more
resources than than we can have at the
office
so the first thing we did is kind of
replaced
celery with kubernetes
so instead of sending tasks as salary
tasks
we've kind of sent pods directly into
the kubernetes cluster still on-prem but
that what
enabled us after
approximately at the beginning of this
year
to
deploy the entire infrastructure
into
aws and then not only leveraging just
kubernetes but also
kubernetes
cluster autoscaler which was responsible
to
um to spin up instances up when we need
them and down when we kind of
ended with the generation
and approximately
at the middle of this year we kind of
put all the pieces together and uh
went ga with our self-service platform
um and if i'll
like zoom a bit into uh the uh this
specific page from our face generator
you'll see that
our users our customers can
specify that whatever distribution of
a gender ethnicity eye color look at
directions of the eye expressions and so
on and then when they kind of click on
generate on the generate button the
button
kind of the whole magic at the back end
starts to to work and
the customer gets some kind of a
link to download the data which is kind
of which is much better than getting
some hard drive right
so
that was in a brief um and now we'll
kind of talk about the challenges we've
we've faced when we kind of created this
whole architecture
so we have to keep in mind we want to
make
things uh
much much as fast as we can because
the alternative is manual data
collection orientation we want to be of
course much much better
uh and we want we need to be fault
tolerance because now we're that we're
going to be some service uh we can't
have no one manually uh being there to
uh
to fix stuff
and gpus are expensive and we want to
cut the cost not only for us also for
the customers in the end and we have
lots of customers
that may be generating data at the same
time and we want
all of them kind of to have the same
consistent
service no matter how many customers are
generating at the same time
and the last one is kind of
our developers
can
we want our developers to be able to
test their own changes of the workflows
without having to
kind of bootstrap this entire ecosystem
so if we dream down drill down
specifically the first one will be
regarding the the generation time
so the first thing we did we kind of
splitted the entire generation into lots
of
tinier
independent tasks so
in the first uh the first uh task would
be some kind of a
random generation of a 3d environment
till the extraction of the uh
of the realistic image and the ground
truth
and each and every one would be
something like that
and the thing is that if we have
enough so if we have n environment
generations we need to do and we have
enough resources or and resources to
accommodate
all of these generation at the same time
we could uh potentially finish the
entire generation at the same time of
only one generation right
so
but but now that we've kind of spread
the task into lots of distributed uh
workers
um
things might might like won't like
unnecessarily uh go as you want and and
things might crash
um so
we need we we
this was the kind of the point where we
started
creating agni our workflow orchestrator
and now we have for each workflow we
have one instance that was responsible
for the entire
run
of the workflow and it was kind of
listening to changes coming out from
these
workers and whenever it identified that
some of the tasks
gone missing or might might fail
it kind of was responsible to replay it
make sure it it runs and of course the
entire generation completed successfully
at the end
but when you
when you retry a task you need to make
sure your tasks are
idempotent so
for the ones that are not familiar with
uh with this term so either potency or
an idempotent task means uh no matter
how many times a line i'll run the same
task over and over uh its output will
always be
uh exactly the same so for example if
the this environment generation tasks
started running then fair then the
orchestrator found out and restarted it
and if before it kind of already wrote
some files and now it
instead of overriding them it writes
another
files maybe with the dot copy extension
of something like that now the output is
something else right and the overall
result of the workflow could be very
different
so
the the responsibility of writing these
tasks and making sure they are item
pattern is uh something each developer
uh in datagen when it writes the tasks
logics it keeps that in mind and making
sure the tasks are
idempotent
so we
already kind of talked a bit about
gpu that is
that is very expensive and we want to
make sure we are only using uh the gpus
or the gpu nodes only when we really
need them
and so what we did next is kind of we
even splitted the tasks more so now we
have for each environment generation we
have one task
that is responsible only for the 3d
environment generation which usually
uses only cpu and then after that it
have two dependent tasks
that one of them is using the gpu to
render the realistic image usually
using ray tracing and things like that
and the other
the other task is doing uh some cpu
rendering and extraction of
modalities of textual modalities and
things like that so in this specific
example you can see
that the first two environment kind of
uh were in inside of the process of
generating the 3d environment while the
the lasting environment was kind of done
with the 3d environment generation
and so the next few tasks
kicked in
the first one uh went to the cpu nodes
and only the the one that really
required the gpu went to the gpu nodes
but it's still not good enough that
maybe was good when we were uh working
on-prem or on our own fixed
fixed machines a fixed number of
machines
sorry
but in the cloud we want to make sure we
don't
we don't have instances up and running
if we're not really using them
so now that we've kind of deployed our
infrastructure into uh into aws using
kubernetes we were able to leverage
kubernetes autoscaler which was the one
that uh enabled uh the the
okay it was the one that uh that was
responsible to making sure that uh the
the number of instances or the number of
uh hardware we really we
we we have up and running at each moment
is
specifically the one we need in order to
accommodate the tasks that we already
sent for execution
and we
already talked about being being
resilient and fault tolerant and
having the ability to quickly recover
from failures so why why not leverage
spot instances so
for the ones who doesn't know spot
instances are a special type of
instances the cloud providers
can give you in a really good price
usually i think like something like
tenth of the price of the like if you
compare it to the
to the same type of on demand instances
and
when but but they don't assure you that
the the
instances will be up and running for for
the entire time you uh you want them to
be
uh so instant says my might get down and
taken away from you
but that's usually fine because uh we
are able to recover and each of these
tasks are are usually quite small in in
in runtime
so in in the in the worst case we'll
probably go back only a few minutes
backwards
and of course we have multiple
customers that might
might
might generate data
on the same infrastructure um on the
same day and time
and we want to make sure
each of them get the same exact service
so what we did we kind of added
some new feature into this into agni
our workflow manager
that's now uh is able to for each
customer for each workflow is able to
get some resource capping information
which tells the workflow that how many
resources you can use
in each point of time so in this
specific example you can see two
customers workload each of them is
capped with only two cpus tasks he can
uh generally he can like send for
execution at the
at one time and one gpu task you can set
in one time but
of course these are small numbers in
reality we're talking about
much much uh larger numbers um
we're talking about like overall we're
talking about thousands of instances all
together
um
and we said before that we want to make
sure uh the developer um
have a nice
experience with with
with agni and and with creating
workflows
and and like testing distributed
application is something that is usually
very hard you'll need
lots of
shared components such as
data stores or a shared file system in
this example
even even kubernetes so what we did is
we kind of created a decoupling between
the workflow orchestration and the
creation of the workflow and the part of
the task execution themselves so
uh in production we could have kind of
plug and play for the same workflow you
could have kind of plug and play the
kubernetes executor making sure all the
tasks are being set to kubernetes uh and
for testing we could
use the same workflow plug and play the
the local executor and make uh and and
then the the task will be executed on
some local uh
process pool
so
of course we've kind of made a lot of
progress and and we still have lots of
ongoing challenges such as uh making the
scheduling much
much smarter
uh in the field of estimation of time
and resources
monitoring and visibility
dynamically changing
the workflows capping
helping the developer even
test their test their changes in a kind
of in a more production-grade
environment
and a lot more
and and just to to kind of wrap it up
uh we're now able to
utilize thousands of instances in the
cloud to support our many customers to
generate data at parallel we're talking
about thousands of data points in only a
few hours
and kind of help our customer train
better ai model just like we've kind of
promised at the beginning right
so
usually you'll see these kind of slides
i think in the beginning
um i thought to put it here
um but this is us this is datagen um our
customers are
tech giants from fortune 500 companies
from many verticals um and we are also
hiring so if any of this uh kind of
sounds interesting
please do uh uh contact me or
get into our website or whatever
so thank you
and
[Applause]